casi un año después desde el anuncio del
primer caso de kobe 19 en la ciudad
china de wuhan el origen del nuevo virus
aún es desconocido qué animal transmitió
el coronavirus a los humanos o cuánto
tiempo lleva el patógeno circulando son
algunas de las incógnitas sin resolver
ahora un equipo de investigación de
expertos de la organización mundial de
la salud intentará dar respuesta desde
la zona cero de la pandemia en wuhan y
listo
el post book para king story
todos los estudios deberían ayudarnos a
retroceder en la historia y en el tiempo
al año pasado e identificar áreas zonas
geográficas y un momento en el tiempo en
el que el virus pasó a la población
humana
podría ser un viaje muy largo antes de
que tengamos una comprensión completa de
lo que pasó en cualquier censo la misión
tendrá dos fases y correrá a cargo de
diez expertos chinos y diez
internacionales epidemiólogos y
virólogos expertos en la salud pública y
zoólogos para cubrir todas las ramas del
estudio donde los científicos
internacionales no pudieron entrar al
país tras detectar los anticuerpos en
las pruebas de kobe 19 mientras que en
la estigmatizada wuhan reciben la visita
con optimismo
en primer lugar les doy la bienvenida
esperamos que dejen claro de dónde vino
el virus y que después de eso den a
conocer una conclusión veraz
weiser el equipo inicia su trabajo sobre
el terreno cuando las autoridades chinas
informaron de la primera muerte por
corona virus desde mayo así como la
imposición de nuevos bloqueos a millones
de personas de la provincia nororiental
a la vez que beijing impulsó una campaña
para vacunar a más de 50 millones de
personas antes de las festividades del
año nuevo lunar en febrero